the country may have voted to leave the
European Union but migration to Britain
is on the verge of hitting a record high
over the past year the country has
opened its doors to people from Ukraine
and Hong Kong a smaller number of
migrants have also crossed the channel
on small boats
but it's also businesses that are
bringing people over using the new
skilled Visa route to help plug
crippling staff shortages and since the
beginning of 2021 when the government
introduced its new post-brexit migration
system you can see the number of people
entering Britain on skilled visas has
soared just as businesses started
struggling with post-lockdown staff
shortages
and if we dive deeper into the data we
can see it's the healthcare and it
industries that are relying most heavily
on overseas skilled workers businesses
in these sectors are bringing over
nurses care workers Pharmacists and
software Developers
these are Industries with long-standing
labor shortages
and drilling into the occupations we can
see that nurses and care workers
dominate the skilled Visa route but
chefs accountants and management
Consultants are also coming over in
large numbers
the biggest proportional increases are
being recorded in sectors that form the
country's food supply chain Agriculture
and accommodation and Food Services have
recorded enormous leaps in migrants with
Bakers butchers and Farmers all entering
Britain on skilled visas
businesses in the construction sector
are also using the scheme to offset the
loss of European workers who have been
leaving in recent years
and across the workforce these Europeans
are being replaced by workers from other
parts of the world and as you can see
here it's predominantly Indians that are
making up the shortfall with more than a
hundred thousand coming to Britain on
skilled visas over the past few years
they're being joined by a growing number
of workers from Philippines Nigeria and
the US
so this is the changing face of Migrant
Britain and while the government talks
tough on immigration the country's
post-brexit migration policy is actually
more liberal than ever